Today we'll discuss logic. Logic is a formal language that allows us to
make assertions about the world in a very precise way.
We learn about logic both because it is an important topic and
also because it forms the basis of additional topics such as planning.
We'll start talking about a formal notation for writing sentences in logic.
This formal notation will have things like conjunctions and
disjunctions. Then we'll talk about truth tables, a topic that you probably
already know. We'll talk about rules of inferences like modus ponens and
modus tollens. Finally we'll discuss methods for proving theories [UNKNOWN]
by repetition. One of those methods is called, resolution theorem proving.